foreign
okay so my clicker is not working so
I'll stay close to my laptop
all right uh so hi everyone my name is
Jackie so I'm a I just graduated from
MIT and I'll be joining um on my Easter
and after this program
so let me first talk a bit about
algorithmic fairness so I'm sure
everyone in this room is aware that kind
of data-driven algorithms can have a
huge impact on society and so I think of
the broad question of algorithmic
fairness as when algorithms exhibit some
sort of undesirable disparity that uh in
turn has some impact on society and
there's many ways in which undesirable
disparities can arise and many types of
disparities because I'm going to be
focusing on one common one that happens
in the machine learning setting is which
is that the common source of disparity
is the fact that data sets that
algorithms are trained on are often kind
of non-representative of the population
that we're interested in so to give you
a concrete example um Precision oncology
is the study of kind of personalizing
cancer treatments and there's some
concern that the emergency Precision
oncology might actually deepen
inequalities in the healthcare system
and the reason for this is or one of the
reasons for this is that kind of genomic
sequencing of what's overwhelmingly
represent people of European descent
right so essentially what this is saying
is that there was some sort of bias in
the data generating process and so an
algorithm trained on such data might not
perform well for like all subpopulations
and so
um if you look at the typical uh
approach of the algorithmic fairness
literature uh the typical approach is to
modify the algorithm so that its output
is more fair for some definition of
fairness but if you look at the problem
of if the source of the problem came
from the data then modifying the
algorithm is not really going at the
root cause of the problem
and so one obvious approach to tackle
this problem is to Simply collect more
data right or collect more
representative data and of course this
is not um an easy thing to do but I
claim that sort of one natural way to
collect more data is to Simply continue
collecting data after we've deployed the
algorithm and sort of tried to
continuously update our algorithm
um and in the machine learning space
essentially this idea of continuing to
collect data and updating our algorithm
is essentially the idea of using online
learning right so in online learning and
how the algorithm can try to quote
unquote like obtain better data in order
to improve the policy in the future and
by obtaining better data we essentially
mean kind of like trying all different
actions so that we have enough data and
better estimates of all possibilities
um that for for our learning task at
hand so essentially what I'm saying is
that simply using online learning is a
reasonable solution for some algorithmic
fairness problems and sort of this is a
theoretically grounded claim because
there are many sort of exploration-based
algorithms that are known to
theoretically converge to the optimal
policy in many settings so here I just
mean that if a policy has a sublinear
regrets eventually the policy is always
going to pick the best action and this
is what I call the optimal policy
um but to get to this upside the
downside is that exploration is actually
costly in the short term and this is the
essence of the exploration exploitation
trade-off that I'm sure many of you have
heard about and so basically uh since
exploration is is associated with the
cost so who incurs this cost uh well it
depends on the setting but like for
example in the medical setting uh it'll
be the patience because uh let's say you
have a new drug and you want to learn
whether this new drug will be effective
for this population then you essentially
need to try the drug on some patients
and if the drug wasn't very good then
these patients kind of suffered this
cost of exploration
so essentially what I'm saying is that I
think about online learning
um essentially as a kind of like a cost
allocation problem right so exploration
is something that's necessary It's
associated with the cost and some people
have to incur this cost and uh different
banded algorithms or different online
learning policies might allocate those
costs to different populations
so in our work with my advisor Rebecca
fryas what we do is we study how to
allocate this cost of exploration in a
quote-unquote fair manner so I'm going
to kind of briefly describe the main
results of this work
so the first result is that we show that
canonical algorithms like UCB are unfair
and uh to explain what I mean by this
let me give you a very uh let me walk
through a very simple concrete example
so here in this example we have we have
the canonical multi-arm Bandit problem
like the K arm band a problem with three
arms but I'm adding the notion of groups
and here the notion of groups there's
groups A and B at each time step one of
the two groups arrive and this bipartite
graph specifies which uh arms a
particular group has access to so if
group a arrives uh the central decision
maker has to assign them uh has to take
one of the actions that are available
for this group so this is a very simple
example with just three arms and two
groups and in this example only arm two
is a shared arm between the two groups
and so if we want to learn about arm2
you know we can either get group a to
pull it or we can get Group D to pull it
um and so on
um but if we assume let's let's assume
that
um the rewards satisfy this uh this
relationship so arm two is actually the
worst arm followed by arm one followed
by arm3 in this case you see that
there's actually an asymmetry in how
much regret is incurred when uh both of
these groups pull on two right because
essentially the kind of the other option
for group a is worse than the other
option for Group B and so if as a
central decision maker I only cared
about minimizing total regrets I'm
actually going to I actually want group
a to pull arm2 because we get the same
amount of information regardless of
which group pulls disarm
um and so we show that any algorithm
that tries to minimize total regret like
UCB uh in this example all of the regret
is going to be incurred by group a
um and Z essentially zero regret or
constant regret is going to be incurred
by Group B and this is in some sense
kind of the worst possible outcome in
how the this export cost of exploration
is allocated between these two groups
like all of the cost is incurred by
group a zero cost is incurred by Group B
when you use UCB right or basically any
algorithm that tries to minimize total
regret will essentially try to identify
the subpopulation who are the kind of
the cheapest to explore with
so how we address this problem is that
we formalize a notion of fairness via a
Nash bargaining framework and so I won't
go into the details of this but
basically the main idea is that we
Define a utility we have to Define
utilities for each group to use this
framework and how we Define it is that
we Define it as the decrease in regret
compared to if the group had to explore
on their own so in the previous example
Group B if group a didn't exist like
Group B wouldn't curse the amount of
regret because it still wants to learn
about arm two so it has to pull it
um so we kind of normalize using this
idea of uh when each group has to
explore on their own how much group they
would incur and we define utility as
like how much you regret decrease
compared to this benchmark
um so then yeah so I won't go into the
details but essentially we show that an
algorithm exists that kind of satisfies
this definition of fairness um and then
we show that the price of fairness is
small so basically satisfying this
notion of fairness
um it's not going to minimize total
regret but it will only increase total
regret by a small amount
okay so this is like a very short
summary of this paper um but I'm happy
to talk about this more uh
so now I just want to talk about some
future directions so uh the kind of the
high level idea of this work is that we
are essentially uh thinking about
exploration as an allocation problem and
sort of thinking about how to
um how to allocate this cost um to
different groups and so um so let me
talk about some interesting questions uh
some questions that I think are
interesting so the first of the first
Direction which is like kind of a more
kind of a practical high level question
is essentially the question of when
should exploration actually be used and
I I'm interested in this question is
because I think exploration is something
that's not that prevalent in practice
like whether that be algorithmic systems
or non-algorithmic systems so for
example take uh the hiring setting like
if you're hiring someone like usually
you're not going to hire someone just
for the sake of learning about this
person even though you you they're not
you know that they're not probably not
going to be that good right
um but you know it is the case that like
so I think like greedy algorithms are
very prevalent in practice and um
fortunately it is the case that greedy
does work well under certain regimes so
it was shown both theoretically and
practically that greedy Works reasonably
well but on outside of these regimes you
know it could be like really can lead to
systems being stuck at some local
optimal right so there's this nice paper
by Danielle Lee and others that study
the hiring setting and they actually
show empirically that if you incorporate
exploration you can actually improve
both the quality and the diversity of
new hires uh compared to using a greedy
algorithm which essentially shows that
in hiring actually like this kind of
phenomena is going to be prevalent
um so along these lines I think some a
couple of questions that could be
interesting are sort of one uh kind of
understanding the uh more granularly in
what ways does kind of greedy fail so is
it the case that certain subpopulations
will always be worse off if you use
greedy and while other populations are
better or is it the case that kind of
everyone is worse off and so on and so
forth kind of really understanding what
greedy does in um into these settings
um another question is sort of
um one the argument against exploration
is that is associated with a short-term
cost okay so then maybe can we quantify
the short-term cost of using exploration
compared to just using a greedy
algorithm so like how long do we have to
wait to reap the benefits of exploration
um and then lastly another direction
that I'm interested in is also kind of
understanding uh when sort of multiple
agents or multiple platforms kind of
face a similar Bandit problem so for
example if the platforms are
collaborative this this is the idea of
sort of meta learning and that we can
get like you know better learning
because we have like multiple data
sources
um on the other hand if the platforms
are kind of strategic about like what
Bandit algorithm they use then sort of
um what happens then and there's also
been some recent work where like users
can also be strategic in choosing
platforms and then you can form some
kind of equilibria but essentially in
all these questions I'm interested in
you know is is learning going to be
efficient
um and also how is the cost of
exploration kind of divided amongst
these different agents
and that's it thank you so much
thanks for the great talk questions
yes thank you wonderful talk
um
I have a question right if you mentioned
one way is to get new data another way
which I would like to comment on how
that would compare is to re-weight your
data so I'm just thinking that
well I used to work at Microsoft we had
Xbox data and we tried to use it to
predict sort of Elections and we
realized that all this young males on
Xbox and very few old female women but
for to predict elections we needed so
old female women but it turns out that
we are still
thousands of old female women on Xbox
and by awaiting the
the population to recreate sort of so
you don't you didn't even need to re to
collect new data so in this database if
I had
ten percent of a certain population
which is not of European origin but if I
would in all my algorithm just put a
weight on my data and sort of make sure
that I weigh enough the data of the
underrepresented group
that could sort of mitigate some of the
issues because now you would learn how
to treat cancer for people who have a
darker skin or different skin color or
things like that yeah so can you comment
on how that because that might be much
easier than creating sort of finding
five million people of African origin in
your database for DNA yeah yeah good
question yeah so I think re-weighting
data is a method of is essentially a
method of improving prediction improving
current predictions with the with uh
with the current data set so I I kind of
think of rewriting data as just finding
a better machine learning algorithm
whereas maybe the current machine
learning algorithm we just try to
minimize like you know mean squared
error over the whole population and
maybe if you reweight data you're kind
of saying like oh we also care about
predictions like doing well on
predictions like in each subgroup but I
feel like like ultimately
like ultimately what we want is like
best predictions for everyone and I
think I think like rewriting data can
only get you so far
um right so like when you read my data
there's like a trade-off of like oh like
you know this and certain subgroups it
might do better but in certain subgroups
you might have to do worse and I think
um so I so I think of this as like okay
you're actually trying to improve the
machine learning algorithm to get better
predictions
um but ultimately you do need more data
um if like the ultimate goal is like you
want to kind of uh best predictions for
everyone
yeah okay thank you yeah maybe one more
question
a great work very interesting I think
the idea of specifying to
me it's brilliant I'm just curious about
you already know the labels of the
groups for people uh and what happens if
you don't actually know which group
people belong to if there are latent
group labels yeah yeah so yeah so in
this work and I would say like most of
the problem work in the algorithm
fairness like we assume that groups are
given and in this work we do assume that
the group identities are known
um so I think and I I think this is
reasonable in that like a lot of the
work on algorithm fairness like the
problem really is down boils down to
like certain subgroups that were kind of
you know historically disadvantaged so
there is kind of a natural notion of
groups but I think
um like yeah understanding but I think
like you know like the problem about
algorithmic fairness without where you
don't know groups
um you know kind of along the lines of
like multi-calibration which is what we
talked about in the boot camp
um is interesting but um it's it's like
yeah we don't have this assumption but I
think this is an interesting direction
to kind of understand what happens when
you when you don't know the group labels
yeah thanks
so let's take further questions offline
and the the final Talk of the session uh
will be given by kangning Wong on
approximately a vision bilateral trade